et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
nathalie arthaud bonjour merci beaucoup
et d'être avec nous vous êtes candidate
à la présidentielle pour lutte ouvrière
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre au nom
du groupe ebra fabrice bonjour oriane le
groupe ebra les journaux de l'est de la
france on ne le dit plus mais au précise
quand même nathalie arthaud vous allez
lancer demain votre campagne
présidentielle premier meeting de
campagne demain c'est la troisième
campagne
présidentielle pour vous vous avez fait
0 6% des voix environ les 2 précédentes
fois pourquoi vous présenter à nouveau
mes parts pour porter les intérêts du
monde du travail voilà pour dire que
rien ne changera pour le monde du
travail pour les ouvriers les employés
les salariés ceux qui galèrent entre
périodes de boulot période de chômage
les intérimaires sans renouer avec les
luttes collectives sans se faire
respecter du patronat vous avez on va
beaucoup parler effectivement des
programmes électoraux et de ce que
pourrait faire un tel ou un tel une fois
président de la république mais ce qui
gouverne véritablement la société c'est
là cette loi du profit c'est cette loi
de l'exploitation et ça elle s'abat sur
l'ensemble du monde du travail et face à
elle eh bien nous disons qu'il faut que
les travailleurs se défendent qui renoue
avec les luttes collectives avec les
mouvements sociaux avec les grèves avec
les manifestations donc voilà je porte
cette perspective là dans cette campagne
présidentielle vous avez l'impression
d'être entendus par les travailleurs qui
sont quand même beaucoup plus que j'ai
reçus pour cent des électeurs est-ce que
l'impression
avec moi je suis je sais que quand ils
veulent se battre quand ils veulent se
battre c'est à dire quand la colère un
finalement passe un sur la peur sur sur
l'attentisme et bien c'est vers nous
effectivement qu'ils regardent et c'est
ce qu'il faut qu'on retrouve parce qu'on
le voit bien à 1 c'est pas les élections
qui changent nos vies qui changent nos
vies et ce ne sont pas les élections qui
met un coup d'arrêt à cette crise
climatique à cette crise économique et à
cette crise sociale on est confronté à
un tout un système qui a une logique
c'est un rouleau compresseur où il n'y a
finalement que le free qui compte et
c'est cela qu'il faut arrêter et encore
une fois on ne l'arrêtera pas on ne
l'arrêtera pas au travers des ans des
élections en choisissant lequel parmi
tous les postulants veut gérer cette
société là mais du coup oui
qu'est-ce que vous voulons proposer ces
travailleurs pour améliorer encore leur
vie leurs conditions de travail eh bien
je leur propose ce que les salariés
aujourd'hui de transdev vous savez cette
entreprise donc dans les transports ces
sondes et des conducteurs de bus
maintenant aussi des conducteurs de
train qui travaille pour transdev qui
auparavant était intégré un sur des
régies publiques plus en plus importante
et bien deux de se battre voilà de
défendre leurs salaires de défendre
leurs conditions de travail de s'opposer
à l'allongement du temps de travail de
s'opposer à tout c'est toutes ces
attaques un qui consiste à reprendre des
minutes de pause qui consiste à
intensifier les les les cadences les
salariés de transdev dans la grande
couronne la parisienne sont en grève
pour certains depuis cinq semaines
depuis cinq semaines et sont en grève
pour dire ça suffit ce recul des
conditions de travail ça suffit prendre
être présent à disposition du patron
sans être payé on en veut plus donc
voilà il joue le rapport de force et moi
je suis convaincu que c'est comme ça
cela effectivement qui se feront
respecter donc moi je suis effectivement
candidate pour dire eh bien c'est ce
chemin là qu'il faut suivre sans cela on
vivra ce qui ce qu'il y a dans toutes
les entreprises parce que dans toutes
les entreprises il faut le dire on ne
parle que des profits des super profits
qui sont réalisés et qui sont affichés
là au cac 40 mais c'est super profits
sont un revers une contrepartie pour le
monde du travail c'est plus de précarité
c'est des salaires bloqués c'est une
aggravation des conditions de travail
donc contre cela bah moi je ne connais
qu'une chose la lutte collective mais je
sais on va revenir évidemment sur ce que
ce que vous proposez mais juste sur le
sens de votre nature c'est ça qu'on
comprend pas bien en fait nathalie
arthaud parce que vous nous dites il
faut se battre dans les entreprises il
faut se battre dans la rue il faut des
luttes collectives et c'est pas cette
élection qui va changer quelque chose du
coup vous êtes candidate pourquoi juste
pour être porte parole de ses ouvriers
pour faire entendre leur parole mais pas
pour changer leur vie conclut je défends
une politique je défends une perspective
j'ai une vision oui de la société je
pense que cette société capitaliste nous
mène dans le mur à tous les niveaux au
niveau économique parce que c'est un
crack en ont vaqué qui nous menace qui
plane un qui nous guette et ce à tous
les experts financiers le disent parce
que regarder ces tensions et si rivalité
internationale si ça se trouve demain
cette fameuse guerre froide entre les
etats-unis et la chine elle va se
transformer en guerre tout court qu'est
ce qu'on en sait de la crise sanitaire
de son rebond et c'était ce que le
président de la république a du pouvoir
pour vous pour réaliser par le président
de la république ne maîtrise rien de
tout cela on est dans une société
capitaliste qui agit encore une fois
comme un rouleau compresseur et ils en
sont complètement impuissant face à ça
mais même face
à la crise climatique donc moi si je me
présente effectivement c'est pour dire
que cette société capitaliste
il ne faut pas chercher à la gérer il
faut chercher à la renverser à la
renverser et je je mais comment vous dit
le président de la république mais aucun
pouvoir et c'est pas le président lui
tout seul qui va renverser une société
si la raison d'elle pour laquelle je
m'adresse au monde du travail je
m'adresse à l'écrasante majorité de la
population qui souffre de cette société
et qui réalise que finalement on est
vraiment dans dans dans demande qui qui
n'ont d'ailleurs plus rien à voir l'un
avec l'autre ou d'un côté c'est les
milliards qui qui dégouline qui
dégouline je le dirige j'utilise ce
terme bien consciemment parce que
regardent vous avez vu les chiffres de
la fraude fiscale onze mille milliards
vous avez vu les milliardaires qui ont
augmenté leur faire une de 40% il ya des
femmes et des hommes y compris dans ce
pays qui touche plusieurs millions
d'euros par jour quand mais allons tous
les résumés à
payer 1,1 euro vont mon calcul et euros
après euro vont pas se chauffer
aujourd'hui c'est le cas pour des
retraités pour des femmes des femmes
seules pour des salariés au smic et
galère f voilà qu'est ce que je me les
résumer à ça ces grands patrons les
grandes entreprises est ce que ce ne
sont pas eux aussi qui créent les
emplois pour les milliers de français
qui du coup un emploi et un salaire à la
fin du ve a aujourd'hui il on supprime
aujourd'hui icha ils font tout leur
possible pour charger la mule 1 c'est à
dire voilà on concentre le travail de
plus en plus sur ceux qui sont en emploi
et les autres on les laisse galéré au
chômage dont et c'est comme ça
d'ailleurs que ces fortunes faramineuses
s'accumulent à un pool donc un moment
donné il faut dire stop et moi
effectivement je pense que le président
de la république il a le pouvoir sur
nous sur la population à ça c'est sûr il
a le pouvoir baisser les allocations
chômage y'a pas de problème mais est-ce
qu'il a le pouvoir sur les entreprises
pour qu'elles embauchent partout où il
ya du boulot où il ya du boulot par
dessus la tête et moi je peux vous en
citer non seulement des entreprises mais
je peux vous citer aussi nombre de
secteurs publics où il y aurait des
dizaines des centaines de milliers
d'emplois à créer dans les hôpitaux dans
les ehpad dans les duels il ya aussi un
nombre de secteurs où il ya beaucoup
d'emplois pour voir comment vous
l'expliquez confond l'expliquait son
intérieur tout non ces emplois pour voir
comme vous dites ce sont en grande
partie des emplois qui sont saisonniers
qui sont des emplois uniquement deux
bouches trous qui sont ou alors qu'ils
sont des emplois qui effectivement il ya
des emplois dans le prix d'entrée
ou alors il y a aussi une fraction de
ces emplois qui sont des emplois très
qualifiés
bon eh bien il n'y a pas ces
qualifications
qu'est ce que vous voulez
moi ce qui me frappe même par rapport à
ce chômage voudrais juste terminée là
dessus c'est qu'effectivement on a des
des reportages du matin au soir un
interviewant
des patrons de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration des pme et leurs demandes
en voilà un en tout cas les laisse voile
alors leur demandant ce qu'ils comment
il voit la situation mais est ce que il
y aura un seul reportage qui ira à voir
les des chômeurs et qui leur demanderont
voilà leurs problèmes quels sont leurs
difficultés quelle est la réalité de
leur vie parce qu'en parce que c'est ça
aussi le problème c'est que les chômeurs
1 ils peuvent pas forcément répondre à
n'importe quel coup de sifflet patronale
ils ont aussi ils ont des qualifications
ils ont un métier ils ont d inspiration
ils veulent travailler dans une région
ils ont aussi des droits des chômeurs
vous évoquez beaucoup la question du
temps de travail a notamment de
l'allongement du temps de travail vous
pensez qu'on travaille trop en france je
pense qu'on travaille trop oui bien sûr
on travaille trop la preuve la preuve il
y a 6 millions de femmes et d'hommes qui
cherchent un emploi un vrai emploi donc
il faut à pour vous la solution ce
serait quand la réduction du temps de
travail faucon répartissent le travail
entre tous il faut qu'on leur
répartissent c'est une aberration une
aberration de voir que certains se tuent
au travail et se tuent mais très
littérale de cinq heures ça n'est pas
assez dans votre idée il faut il faut
aller en dessous bien sûr il faut qu on
baisse le temps de travail il faut mais
vous savez c'est pas qu'une question de
nombre d'heures travaillées c'est aussi
l'intensité du travail c'est et il s'est
intensifiée de partout et et regarder
comment
les femmes et les hommes se suze
usent leur santé au travail eux n'en
peuvent plus tout ça on doit leur
ajouter autant de transport ont donc non
aujourd'hui c'est décadence jeu j'ai
discuté récemment avec des ouvriers de
psa cité lantiss maintenant un qui
explique avec les cadences qui sont
imposés un certain nombre de dents siens
ne peuvent plus suivre n'arrive plus à
suivre et ça on peut le dire dans les
ehpad c'est le cas des auxiliaires de
vie c'est le cas mais de nombre de noms
en fait de salariés à une pression
maintenant au travail je parlais des
conducteurs de transdev aujourd'hui on
alors demande de prendre leur bus en dix
minutes il faut qu'ils courent ils
doivent arriver au boulot il faut qu'ils
courent vérifier que les feuilles les
fleurs les feux clignotants fonctionne
qui prennent le volant et s'est donc
c'est sale boulot aujourd'hui n'était de
course contre la montre permanente je
profite pour finir sur cette question
importante du chômage l'insee prévoit un
fort taux de recul du taux de chômage à
7,8 pour cent pour le troisième et
quatrième trimestre 2009 à un niveau qui
n'a jamais été atteint depuis 2008
qu'est ce que vous dites face à ces
chiffres jeudi que le chômage ce n'est
pas une statistique
c'est des millions de femmes et d'hommes
qui désespèrent de trouver un véritable
emploi de pouvoir s'inscrire dans la
durée
réaliser qu'il ya de moins en moins de
personnes qui sont au chômage
aujourd'hui eh bien vous savez ces
chiffres cachent le hic h tous les
petits boulots il cache le fait qu'un
certain que beaucoup sont utilisés je le
redis comme des bouche trous qu'ils ne
peuvent même pas se dire voilà je peux
compter sur ce salaire je peux compter
sur ce boulot ils sont sur un siège
éjectable c'est des cdd cdi intérim les
mesures gouvernementales venant du jour
au lendemain privés de leur ca sur les
mesures gouvernementales pendant cette
crise il fonde solidarité et les
exonérations de cotisations et le
chômage partiel est ce que vous
reconnaissez que l'état était présent
aux côtés des salariés mais vous savez
pour un salarié même ce chômage partiel
c'était tout sauf un cadeau un tout sauf
un cadeau quand tous les cafés allait
faire alors je veux jouer et cours non
mais quand vous avez 1400 euros pour
vivre quand vous avez 1500 euros pour
vivre vous êtes en difficulté en
permanence quand vous touchez votre
salaire plein donc en taux de salaire il
est amputé ne serait-ce qu de 52 82 100
euros eh bien c'est la galère et ça ça a
été vécu par des millions de femmes et
d'hommes sans parler que là vous me
parlez vous du chômage partiel mais vous
savez quand même que dès le 1er
confinement dès la première semaine du
confinement c'est des centaines de
milliers d'intérim de cdd qui sont
retrouvés au chômage total au chômage
complet et il faut quand même pas les
oublier cela parce que ils sont en
nombre très important bien sûr on va
parler d'un sujet qui inquiète les
français c'est la hausse des prix de
l'énergie alors la hausse des prix de
l'énergie le gouvernement propose des
mesures pour faire face à cette hausse
notamment tout ce qui est pétrole gaz et
cetera vous saluer ces mesures ouais
j'avoue que ça m'a fait rire on est à la
sixième hausse du gaz sixième hausse du
gaz sur l'année ça fera près de 60 % de
hausse et là le premier ministre arrive
en nous expliquant qu'ils aillent y
aille et il a un bouclier c'est bon tout
les bas elles ont été tirées l'a1 le mal
est fait finalement et qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent
l'augmentation des pensions de retraite
l'augmentation du smic hauteur non non
donc moi je pense que face à cette
question là ce qui est important c'est
que ces deux c'est de remettre sur la
table la nécessité d'augmenter les
salaires et surtout de les indexer de
les indexer les internationaux voire
réel de les indexées sur l'inflation
réelle ce serait la moindre des choses
voyez j'ai encore rencontré une
auxiliaire de vie qui se déplace avec
sasson automobile l'essence a augmenté
et on sait et on ne peut très bien
mesurer la hausse depuis le bleu le 1er
janvier donc c'est une hausse de 20%
quelque chose comme ça 20% eh bien ces
auxiliaires de vie demande juste que
leurs indemnités kilométriques soit
augmenté d'autant et bien non ça se
passe pas voilà ça se fait pas vous
trouvez ça normal c'est pas normal donc
il faut que les salaires mais aussi les
pensions de retraite les minima sociaux
soient indexés de suivent le
l'augmentation de tous ces prix et
l'inflation qui réel à l'inflation que
nous mesurons quand nous faisons le
plein de l'essence quand nous
remplissons notre caddie et par
l'inflation mesurée par l'insee parce
qu'elle est toujours en retard d'un
train et est toujours en train de
sous-estimer la vraie situation donc
voilà c'est une augmentation des
salaires mais vous savez ça moi je ne
vais pas faire comme les autres
candidats un qui jettent leurs promesses
ainsi moi je suis élue présidente de la
république
en l'occurrence ils ont ils ont un
programme c'est ce qu'attendent un peu
les électeurs savent et candidat la
pression si on a bien compris ce que
vous voulez sur le social et pour les
travailleurs c'est très clair par
exemple sur un sujet comme le climat et
la transition énergétique quelles sont
vos propositions là juste pour vous dire
que vous savez je pense pas que les
électeurs attendent ce genre de
promesses électorales dont ils savent
savent pertinemment qu'elles qu'elles
attirent ou dans la poubelle dans la
poubelle moi je le redis ces
augmentations de salaires elles sont
mille fois légitime le smic même pas
1300 euros nets c'est indigne il faut
les arracher de leur relation salaires
et le doublement de la session refait
soeur par exemple que propose anne
hidalgo vous en pensez quoi moi je pense
ça serait tout à fait légitime a donc
vous avez un point commun avec anne
hidalgo me soyez prête à discuter avec
les pigeons vous savez moi je trouve que
ce serait tout à fait légitime mais
légitime aussi de multiples de doubler
beaucoup d'autres salaire ça c'est pas
une utopie à la prod ça se fait chez nos
voisins donc ils sont payés deux fois
plus mais c'est une question encore une
fois de rapport de force de moyens cet
argent on va le prendre ou moi je pense
qu'il va falloir aller l'arraché au
profit vos dividendes est ce que j'ai
envie de dire dans cette campagne au
monde du travail c'est que les choses
elles sont simples c'est une question de
rapport de force soit ce sont leurs
dividendes ou alors c'est nos salaires
c'est leur profit ou c'est nos emplois
voilà c'est les les sinécures le luxe
pour quelques-uns ou alors ce sont nos
retraites on n'a pas le choix c'est une
question de combat justement un mot sur
les retraites la réforme des retraites
n'aura a priori pas mieux d'ici la fin
du quinquennat vous en région iss à ben
je moi je suis absolument opposé à tout
reculé des retraites voilà je change et
là on chante on fait pour s'habiller
après quoi le blem avec le régime de
retraite actuel laisse que la société
est ce que la société n'est pas riche
l'économie repart 1 écoutez moi
j'entends bruno le maire mais qui est
ravi de la situation économique nous
explique que tout va bien tous les
signaux sont au vert il ya de l'argent
ça redémarre et bien qu'on aille prendre
dans cet argent cet argent il est
produit par qui c'est le fruit du labeur
de la sueur du monde du travail et
devrait lui revenir à des finances au
financement des retraites avec les
profits des grandes entreprises et bien
pourquoi pas mais on n'est pas vraiment
sur la même échelle mais bien sûr là on
est sur la même échelle vous avez vu ses
profits 58 milliards au premier semestre
à veut dire plus de 100 milliards sur
l'année en deux ans en 2020 bien sûr que
c'est bien sûr les reichel 300 milliards
d'euros nathalie arthaud comme en
rajouter 100 milliards je peux vous dire
que ça ça nous sort complètement 1,2 du
du problème bien sûr qu'il faut prendre
l'argent là où il est je trouve pour
louis un sujet il n'y a pas de sujet
réforme des retraites il ya ici il ya un
sujet il faut les améliorer les réformes
des retraites parce que les retraites
elles sont indignes pour beaucoup de
femmes et d'hommes qui ont bossé toute
leur vie et qui aujourd'hui on voit des
reportages aujourd'hui n'a ont du mal à
se chauffer vous vous rendez compte je
trouve ça indigne dans un pays riche
comme le nôtre et encore une fois on
peut pas dire que tout va bien que c'est
la prospérité que on nage dans dans les
milliards un pôle est allé dire à ceux
qui travaillent ceux qui portent la
société eh bien il faut sacrifier vos
retraites il faut sacrifier vos salaires
il faut sacrifier la sécurité de
l'emploi on peut pas dire ça et moi
voilà je je je ne sais on a bien compris
en attentant prix natalia et je lui
tends le riche en train de revenir les
salons avant de terminer puisque vous
parlez de dargaud vous êtes d'accord
avec sa proposition doublement des
salaires des professeurs je suis pour le
fait de se battre parce que ça ne
tombera pas du ciel plus largement est
ce que vous discutez avec d'autres
candidats de gauche pour cette élection
présidentielle où vous irez de toute
façon et vous acceptez cette division à
gauche pour le moment je porte une autre
voie vous l'avez bien compris vous
l'avez d'ailleurs souligné un mois jeu
concours dans une catégorie très spécial
la catégorie communiste révolutionnaire
vous voyez il n'est pas la catégorie
communiste où la france est soumise pour
vous c'est encore une autre catégorie je
ne veux pas être la gestionnaire de
cette société qui courent à la
catastrophe vous avez posé le problème
de la catastrophe climatique écologique
et c'est une catastrophe moi je veux pas
être les gestionnaires de cette société
là je pense que sans combattre cette
course aux profits sans combattre cette
propriété privée capitaliste 1 qui qui
conduit à à ce gaspillage inouïe qui
conduit à ces inégalités à ses
injustices mais aussi
à cette désorganisation totale de
l'économie à aso à ce gaspillage on
n'arrivera à rien est-ce que vous avez
l'impression vos thèmes de campagne sont
entendus dans cette campagne
présidentielle natale r tout est-ce que
c'est pas quelqu'un comme eric zemmour
qui arrive à imposer ses thèmes à
l'heure actuelle dans la campagne vous
savez ils sont très entendue dans le
monde ouvrier dans le monde des
entreprises tout ce que je viens de vous
parler assez des problèmes réels qui
sont vécus après je vous concède que sur
les plateaux de télévision oui c'est
plutôt eric zemmour que nathalie arthaud
que l'on entend mais je vous assure que
des relais car j'ai pas tout l'air et
que sur les os la télévision pour vous
et les xénons ils ne parlent pas une
catégorie de la population aux autres
districts ne parle pas alors à l'heure
actuelle sans aucun doute il surf sur
des préjugés qui existent ils les attise
il les alimentent mais moi je et écoutez
moi je le combat de toute façon je le
combats quand j'entends les républicains
pour vous en dire autant non mais c'est
moi quand je l'entends dire que les
immigrés musulmans sont inassimilables
mais écoutez je vous garantis sont très
bien assimilé au monde du travail très
bien assimilé au monde d exploiter ce
sont eux qui font les boulots les plus
difficiles sans eux n'y a pas un
aéroport pas un chantier dans le
bâtiment cluny fonctionnerait il porte
la société moi ce que j'ai envie d'avoir
cette campagne c'est que c'est autant
cette société est le rappel appartient
autant ces travailleuses et ces
travailleurs qu'à eric zemmour dans la
question de l'état de la gauche molle
inquiète
je me sens pas faire partie de cette
gauche gouvernementale qui a renoncé
finalement à changer la société moi ma
confiance et mes espoirs il se tourne
vers vers ce monde du travail qui
forcément un moment donné va renouer
avec avec avec 7,7 objectifs de la
changer cette société du tout au tout et
de mettre fin à cette société qui est
basée sur l'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme merci beaucoup merci la télé
merci devenu no 20 ce matin et nous
parler de vos propositions et de la voie
que vous portez dans cette campagne
présidentielle merci fabrice ans
[Musique]